daily wire has their own chocolate brand
and it's got better ingredients the the
daily Jeremy's chocolate has like four
ingredients at no preservative garbage
it's like cocoa cocoa butter sugar and
milk or something isn't that part of the
populist movement too it's not just a
political thing it's even a health thing
yeah you know there's there's oil to it
seed oils all this other stuff but you
know here's an interesting phenomenon
that has been happening really I would
say Post Obama more than anything maybe
it's liberals being anti-war to being
pro-war but even that's a little more
nuanced here's here's something that's
direct and right in your face
it used to be that the First Amendment
and the Second Amendment were huge
liberal causes liberals were always
going to go to bat for the First
Amendment liberals were always going to
go to bat for the Second Amendment where
that's not a liberal belief anymore now
if you want to be a modern day American
liberal Progressive Democrat your
anti-free speech your anti-second
amendment I mean that's that's been the
phenomenon that we've witnessed it's a
complete inversion